let's go back I told you everything I
understand this is difficult Michael I
don't know where she is and even if I
did I'd never tell you I would never
tell you know it's difficult to accept
she's a very dangerous individual if she
contacts you you must tell us otherwise
you're putting yourself and your entire
family at risk
do you understand Michael Mike
you
[Music]
on Halloween night there's a sort of
shadow maybe all this is happening for a
reason nightmares is happening
and it all leads back to here
[Music]
this thing
[Music]
and what have you done nothing
what is wrong with my boy
[Music]
I don't understand
she was
[Music]
[Applause]
like reaching in tourniquets
anyone knows who to destroy this thing
it's will
oh my god
don't you think it's weird
I really seem to hang out in the world's
about the end
it's not like it was before it's grown
it's Judgment Day
which is why really doesn't much help as
we can get
you should go now someone's here
[Music]
you should let that bad back what that
one with the nails
[Music]
you